so don't realize how long have you known
James Franco um I've known him for five
years we were in our first year at nyu
together in the grad program so we were
classmates um and we were like our first
semester you do like a four-minute black
and white silent film and you get like a
crew of four people and we got put
together in the same group so we kind of
became friends from there from working
together oh very nice oh yeah and so
then um how did the idea of you
directing one of the stories in palo
alto come about how did he pitch that to
you um it was i received a text message
saying do you want to adapt my beast
short stories um and i was really
excited of course and he asked me to
adapt them into a future script for my
thesis film um but yeah basically he
asked he had these stories about
childhood and he thought I would be a
good fit I think for those specific
three stories that are not about
teenagers but they're all about these 10
year old boys um and I think there was
just like this vibe or this feeling that
we would that I would be good for these
big ones about childhood um so it's very
simple and you know I guess he was
familiar with my work from film school
and we had crude together on films for a
number of years on during film school
which three stories are they think
neither called the first one is called
Yosemite and that's in the Palo Alto
collection and then the other two are in
the book California childhood one is
called Peter Parker um and has to do a
spider-man and then the other one is
called grand illusion okay okay yeah and
then the you 71 I just know a little bit
about just from the IndieGoGo campaign
manager where someone goes on a trip
right with their family to you something
yeah it's like two brothers go on a trip
to Yosemite with their dad and their
kind of estranged because they haven't
seen the done in a long
and things kind of take a bad turn okay
how are you getting into it like the
characters minds for for these films
just just buy one we're reading the book
and yeah well the I love the story so
much that I kind of like preserve the
atmosphere of each of them and the movie
the script became this triptych so each
part of the film kind of deals with 11
boy and the boys are all friends and you
kind of follow their friendships um but
it's fun because you get to be in each
boys mind for you know each segment of
the film so you know there's like three
of them inserts yeah why you think that
you resonate with these characters just
did you have a similar childhood was it
something you felt a kinship with these
I'm like actually grew up in France so I
but so I kind of had a different
childhood but I have my mom's American
and I she's from the bay area so I did
spend summers there and I'm the same age
as James so there is a kinship in terms
of the time period and the places and I
lived in Berkeley for several years so
I'm familiar with area um so there is
definitely a kinship and then I say like
a little bit of like an outsider's
perspective to which I think makes it
interesting also because it's a very
male world and it's all about fathers
and sons and so I think it's interesting
that have a woman direct and kind of
have an outsider's perspective also on
those characters